bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got wuda
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
yeah thank you so much for having me
anthony really excited to be on
all right so i'm going to cheat we're
going to start off with a bang uh if all
of d5
and decentralized financial applications
regardless of where they get built if it
all
works what does the world of finance
look like like what is the dream of all
this
so where i got so excited is um you know
my previous company that i built uh
sakfi with some of you will know
um which raised a lot of money 700
million dollars in total
but in a completely centralized you know
finance environment
with all the transaction costs involved
including you know swift wires that cost
me 50
50 bucks to make i need to wait for
fedwire cutoffs dates sometimes when we
do options financing
like all these inefficiencies that we
see in a centralized finance market
in a future where d5 just drives a lot
of these processes i see a much more
sort of frictionless
environment where even you know you me
anthony we can
we can trade our shares if we want
without a broker intermediary custodian
for which we need to pay all these fees
and many of these other applications
that we see that just gets me so
exciting just be
based on the world that i'm coming from
and i think that's really what uh you
know what i see as sort of
you know the real future uh feature
looks like if you ask me
for sure and so when we start talking
about decentralized uh applications
um is this something where you're
thinking hey an entirely new world is
gonna get built and it's gonna basically
be the challengers uh and it's gonna be
exclusive of the legacy players or do
you see a world where those legacy
players eventually are gonna come in
and uh they're gonna say hey we have to
adopt the decentralized
applications and kind of play in this
new world because that's where all the
value is going to flow
so i think you have always two cams
right you have the the sort of the sort
of
crypto or d5 purist that say you know g5
will revolutionize the
role of finance it will completely
replace the existing system
i'm more of the camp that say yes some
some applications you know might be sort
of completely replaced but we also have
to be realistic like
governments are not standing still you
have organizations even such as the sec
that are increasingly looking at like
hey how can these
technology developments be a benefit for
us how can we sort of help
the market sort of regulate this and
adopt this and i would say that you know
the decentralized technology can
actually really also help centralized
institutions or institutions that we
have today
just be more efficient you know reduce
their cost of operating business and
therefore in the end
reduce the cost that it uh that it costs
consumers to access those products
and i think we will see there it's
therefore like a blend where these
technologies can also help you know some
of the
products that we see today in the market
yeah and it's fascinating talking to you
about this because you built a very
successful kind of centralized financial
application right and a product and a
company
and so talk a little bit just about uh
kind of the cognitive dissonance there
right you were very successful building
the centralized
uh entity now you're spending most of
your time in the decentralized world
uh is it something where you're
basically saying there's a binary winner
winner-take-all system
or do you think that actually that
centralized world will also still kind
of co-exist
maybe it's not as popular maybe it
doesn't uh kind of die right away
but you know that there is some value
still left there
yeah absolutely you know what we've
built at sacrifice for those that sort
of don't know that are tuning in
uh we we kind of pioneered the concept
of providing financing based on private
company assets so we we helped a lot of
people in the early days of uber
exercise their stock options got them
the financing to pay for the taxes
and so on and so forth but what we had
to sort of
develop from a central you know central
finance point of view
is we need to make sure that you know
the shares can't go anywhere
where we have when we have to financing
so we need to find sort of a custodian
solution
we need to make sure that uh we have
production around terms of the financing
so we had onshore funds offshore funds
all kinds of legal
that sort of had to sort of all address
this and
the reason i got excited about d5 is
when i was speaking to my co-founder at
the time
uh olivier rossi newton who co-founded
hive
it's like if i had to do sakfi all over
again there would be so many different
instances where i could actually
leverage defy or
or a smart contract to to make that
entire process more
more efficient so i don't think it's a
winner takes all market i think we will
i'm also very excited to see you know
applications that will live a little bit
on the edge
of centralized finance and d5 because
sometimes you it you still require
some kind of authority even in
decentralized applications that
you know that that brings some
governance to the table effectively
and i think um yeah that's where we see
we'll see a lot of innovation happening
for sure
yeah so let's talk about uh d5
technologies i'm an advisor to
the company uh you and olivier came
together uh and started this
let's talk about just the impetus for
the idea right you're at sec phi
uh you guys decide that you're gonna do
this what is the
um kind of original idea why do it
so when olivier started high four years
ago
he had a very simple uh sort of thesis
of why this company would work you know
now we can go on coinbase which went
public today and probably see a very uh
amazing debut where people can pretty
easily buy bitcoin if you look four
years ago
there's people still scrambling where do
i go which parties do i trust there was
still a lot of hacks at the time now a
lot of these classrooms have matured
but what he in the end and this is the
genius behind what he did with hive he
said to people okay look you want to get
exposure to crypto exposure to bitcoin
ethereum
just buy my stock now we're in an
environment where we've had bitcoin
we've had ethereum smart contracts we
had a little bit of the ico create
uh create craziness that had that
happened but now we have an evolution
of technologies that you know um are all
around d5
and have all these new sort of
opportunities with them whether you're
talking about yield farming staking
liquidity pools etc that have all been
developed
but increasingly complicated like i have
a computer science degree
it takes me it takes even me a long time
to make some of these trades
so coming back to what olivier did what
d5 technologies really is is like look
you want to get exposure to define a
diversified fashion just buy our stock
so we're giving retail investors
basically exposure and also institutions
to what i think
is the next wave of financial innovation
that is happening um and bringing that
to the public markets
for sure and walk through a little bit
in terms of just the way that you get
a company like this into the public
market and then how you capitalize it
yeah so we um so the way that we sort of
got it into the market is we started d5
as a private company we found like a
really
good uh public company to uh to work
with in the canadian market so we we
kind of like
to took over that company um uh with
with our with our company d5 holdings
and then effectively did an uplifting to
the neo which is
tier one exchange in canada has a as a
sort of superior
uh corporate governance especially if
you want to sort of attract
um institutions and and how you
capitalize it is
we really focused on you know we have
had a couple of different assets already
that we
that we know we wanted to build out so
one of them is uh
we have an etn business you know where
we create uh uh
where we basically allow people to to to
buy uh
exposure to d5 in in their brokerage
accounts you know just like you have uh
grayscale bitcoin trust and ethereum
trust we effectively have now uh
developed
the first bitcoin zero ethereum zero
coming out with some of the uh
some of the protocols that uh that are
on d5 such as ave synthetic curve and
etc
and for that of course you need uni you
need capital to sort of run that so we
did a private placement
uh in in the quarter one of this year of
a 10
million dollar canadian and we'll expect
to sort of uh you know capitalize the
bitter
business going forward as well for sure
and as you kind of think through this
uh this is a whole new sector right i
think a lot of people don't understand
that right just because you understand
finance doesn't mean you necessarily
understand decentralized finance and a
lot of what's happening right here
uh talk to us about just what you're
seeing kind of on the ground and in the
trenches right so
there's lots of activity people are
really excited but what are you actually
seeing being built and where is the
adoption occurring of these products
yeah i think i think a really big
adoption also when i
just empirically like if i just look at
my network and stuff and how people sort
of transact
you see a real really big adoption
happening for example on stable coins
right so you have of course we have usdc
we have usdt but you also have new
protocols such as fracs which are sort
of more sort of algorithmic stable coins
and you just see now that those things
are becoming more stable the sec
came out with some um with some really
positive guidance around stable coins
you you see that people are now
increasingly more just accepting that
they can wire usdc to each other rather
than making a bank wire and i think that
that frictionless payment sort of system
system that is happening on the
blockchain
i think that's one of the things i am
super
excited about and where you see a lot of
i think um
you know good innovation happening is
for example the price discovery on
coinbase that is happening
was already public on ftx for example
right so
coinbase shares were already traded i
think for about three to three to six
months
on for example ftx where uh people were
you know
doing price discovery and it seems to be
pretty close to where it's going to open
open today i think other areas where we
see a lot of like
innovation of course happening is is in
a is one of the key use cases is lending
right so you have anywhere from aveda
curve
there's there's a lot of stuff stuff
happening there and it's kind of very
interesting to follow sort of where that
um where that will go but these are kind
of the three sort of main areas that i
that i that i'm tracking and that sort
of i'm following and i'm excited about
for sure and so when you think about the
team walk us through kind of who makes
up the team today and then
how you guys are thinking about adding
people in the future
yeah we have um we have a pretty
distributed diverse team
so um uh maybe just talking around like
what what we do
so so we have of course our etn business
so we acquired an asset that uh olivia
and i also built the last three years uh
called valor structured products
we have um we have an amazing ceo in
place there called uh called diana biggs
who used to
head up hsbc innovation and also their
their sort of crypto crypto division and
a lot of the um
the the things that hsbc did in that
market so she is she's running that
business for us
uh together with johan buttonstrom which
is the one of the
founders of coin shares which also went
public uh recently
so as the wealth of knowledge on the on
the kind of the trading side
we have another trading desk in uh soup
switzerland um
where where have most of our trading
happen some of some seasoned
professionals from uh
from ubs and the likes and um and who
sort of oversee that business then on
our venture side so as you may have seen
we
invested of course in sovereign which
we're super happy to sort of join
and we have an entire team in
on the west coast that kind of sources
all those deals and that's really great
right because
for public markets investors especially
retail investors they're just not going
to have exposure to this kind of type of
deal flow
right you know you also know probably
it's really concentrated in the one
percent of the one percent that kind of
sees the best deals and is able to
evaluate them
and we do that for users for our
customers so that you know we provide
them early access to this uh to this
and then we have uh you know of course
my co-founder olivier ross newton
who is uh who founded high blockchain
technology since one of the most traded
companies in uh in canada
uh pretty much every day one of most
liquids so he has a lot of wealth
wealth of experience in kind of the
canadian capital markets and kind of
also growing a public company
and that's kind of the sort of i would
say like the main um
the main team and then we have have also
an amazing guy um curtis on board who
does all of our marketing and kind of
helps to sort of build the brand and you
know we just launched a new website and
and and oversees all of that so that's
uh that's kind of like how everything
comes together and you ask about hiring
yeah we're definitely looking to hire on
the etm business
you know so if i can plug that i will
plug that any day you know traders
or or on the tech side always need help
there so
so that's kind of where we're really
looking to expand come from in a coming
few months
for sure and so talk a little bit about
um this idea of hey there's one stock
uh somebody can buy and they can get
exposure to kind of multiple
businesses within this uh kind of sub
sector really of
the crypto industry um when you talk to
investors what's kind of the pros of
having that single stock to buy and then
what are the risks or the downside
yeah i think the the pros i would really
compare to like investing in coinbase
right so if you're investing in coinbase
uh even though of course we're not a
hundred billion dollar market cap
company yet
uh but if you could just compare it on
sort of the investment pieces it's
you know coinbase will make money
whether it's really bitcoin
that's going up or whether it's ave or
something else they just
if you invest in coinbase you're
probably taking a long term uh
a long term long position on actually
where crypto is going and how that
company is performing
so i think for for investors we're
really good in that kind of concept
right
whether people buy our etns in ave or in
synthetics or curve or or any kind of
other it doesn't really matter like we
make money of course on kind of the
products that we offer
and same thing goes for some for the
other products that i mentioned before
so that's really the advantage that you
can take a more sort of diversified view
and that's really good for people that
don't want to
that don't fully understand maybe like
what kind of
exposure to buy and defy d5 and the
downside is of course
is that you probably if you really
understand let's say
frax or you really understand synthetics
or ave
and you know you could of course have
superior returns by simply buying that
one
you know yeah uh that one token or that
one protocol that you that you really
like
so that's kind of one of the downsides
right a more diversified approach also
means that you
have you know a sort of dampened um a
return on some of the the
outliers uh that's kind of like uh what
i would say
yeah it makes a ton of sense it's also i
think part of this like holding company
strategy if you if uh
i can call it that is uh you get both
investments plus operating businesses as
well right and i think that's part of
you know i first started talking to you
guys about it what becomes really
interesting uh for somebody like me is
like one i gotta learn a bunch
that's going on uh but two is you have
the
uh the direct capital exposure uh but
also even in a bull or bear market
you've got these operating businesses
that
should perform exactly as well and so
it's a kind of a very unique uh
unique structure um let's talk a little
bit about nfts it seems like everyone is
talking about that
every day right now uh what are you guys
doing there what are you personally
interested in
and then kind of how do you see that
industry as it continues to evolve
yeah so so personally like i'm super
bullish on the entire space i think that
um when you
when you look at uh so i'm actually by
uh you know when i was 16 i was actually
a professional
professional gamer and i still remember
that you know you have
you know what always made the rounds is
like who had the coolest wallpapers
right and it's always being shown around
and there's all these
people that do the animes and there's a
real market for these type of digital
assets and i think
it is beyond what people believe there
to exist right there i think they're
that market is actually bigger than
people that people think
but they're you know up until now
there's not really a way to
you know reward these creators right
we've also seen the entire
sort of meme wave where there is a real
there's a real like
want of people like i want to have that
meme because that's the coolest meme and
there's this
entire community which i think people
are overlooking that
that creates value and this is not
really so different if you compare it to
maybe and i mean that not without
disrespect uh
with disrespect for something old money
that wants to have this fan go
in their house you know or wants to have
a certain monet or something
else it's just a different way of doing
things and the new
sort of the new millennials and stuff
the new generation
is much more you know open to how art is
being created and i think that is a
fluid concept
so from that perspective i'm super
bullish on the industry
i think it will have this natural this
is a market that will naturally have
it's like sort of
ups and then it will cut people will
kind of see where it settles i think
that will definitely happen
like i tried to you know i tried to be
funny and try to buy an nft for a friend
of mine and i couldn't find something
under like 1800
or something so and so that was kind of
something that i cut very short
um and it's something from a d5
perspective that we're looking at as
well so we're
we're not really in the in the in the
business of of trading
you know these nfts i don't think that's
our expertise but we we would be looking
at like
interesting assets that we can you know
potentially
collaborate with fund uh take a minority
or majority position in
uh in order to you know grow the sort of
um yeah exposure that we can give our
users to what is what is essentially
also
a decentralized market so yeah that's
how we're looking at it
got it and so when you start thinking
about let's take nfts as an example it
seems like it's a very global market
right this is not just a western finance
market um
talk a little bit about just what you're
seeing across the globe if there's
specific
um you know maybe geographies that
you're really excited about or if
there's
conversations that you've had with
people around the world any kind of
learnings or takeaways
for people um on that like kind of
global perspective
well what i think what i think is um
what i think is interesting from a
global perspective
is that you know i'm a big fan of uh you
know some some a few japanese
artists for example and if i want to buy
you know on artsy for example i
i've been looking for a really long time
for specific you know pieces of art
that i would like to to buy from this
artist and they are like they're they're
prince
you know but there's a limited edition
prince and where i'm going with this is
that a lot of these prints are being
sold in china
um you know and and the thing is there
you don't really know
like if it's real you know or if it's
maybe a counterfeit or
there's a lot of things happening there
and i think what makes it so interesting
from a global perspective is that nft
can really bring with it sort of a
provenance
for those who don't know it that you can
kind of like trace
you know from from who it owns today all
the way back to its owner so in
a traditional painting you you could all
go in a van gogh you could go to like
the museum that currently holds it all
the way to when van gogh actually
painted it for example
that needs to be there otherwise you're
you know your painting is not considered
real or genuine in most cases
and what is interesting you know for the
nfts is that i can just trace
what the provenance is i can see it on
the blockchain so from a global
perspective i think it really broadens
your mind in terms of like buying
you know nft art from very for example
china or japan
or you know french art that is owned by
a chinese person
where you may consider like it might be
fraught in a traditional world but now i
can actually trace it and look at it so
i think that makes
this world of art much more global and
much more interesting and inclusive
that's why i met you on it yeah no i i
think that makes a ton of sense and so
um let's go back to this idea of uh
there's a new world and then kind of an
old world right and those aren't
necessarily
completely descriptive but we'll use
them just for the conversation um
and so if we start thinking about like
the analog legacy world
it seems like some of those
organizations have woken up right the
reason why goldman sachs has been around
for a century
is because we've navigated every
technology trend as it's uh popped up
and become a threat and they figure out
how to how to kind of do it
are there specific things that you think
in d5
uh regardless of where it's being built
that will naturally be the first
entry points for some of these legacy
organizations is it decentralized
lending is it no they're just going to
go trade on decentralized exchanges like
how do you think they uh kind of
interface with a lot of this new
technology first
yeah it's it's a very good question and
i think you know
organizations such as you mentioned like
goldman sachs and stuff and then this is
not really based on my conversation with
goldman or any of these institutions but
if i
if i were to look at this i would
probably look at okay what are my
operational processes in my own business
and how can i make those more efficient
right so for example um you know ripple
maybe to use them as an example
like in the back end and some of these
processes whether it's visa or
mastercard or use some of the others
that they have in kind of their you know
sort of network if you will they're
already using what is essentially
blockchain technology to make their own
internal processes either more efficient
or more transparent
or just safer right because everything
is sort of um
built on the blockchain so i think where
you see the you know
sort of low-hanging fruit it's probably
going to be those solutions
i think if you look at really like
decentralized lending
um i think institutions will will need
some time
in order to really become the major
liquidity providers i think currently
it's still like high net worth maybe
family offices
at the maximum that is kind of in the
space it's a lot of individuals
i think we'll you know there's the stuff
that needs to be answered around also
kyc right who is the other party
aml and i think there's a lot of
interesting things happening there for
example with shift network
where we invested that is time kind of
addressing some of these things
um uh before that we would see real
adoption there but that's kind of like
how i see maybe some of the paths there
to
to to to adoption in the more
traditional sense
yeah and what's so fascinating to me is
that the conversation and question
around like do we need the legacy
institutions right if the legacy
institutions never come in
right uh can this be successful and can
it kind of stand on its own without any
of their support or participation
yeah i think again it's it's like it's
like
um you know it's again where sort of the
real future and what sort of the middle
you know where are we where are we today
and i think you know d5 went of course
from about 500 million two years ago to
now 52
billion dollar market gap but the same
thing is is like
which is amazing if you know that's your
market cap of maybe uh uber when it went
public or something
but if you look at the global financial
market i mean we're talking about a
different animal right we're talking
about
trillions and trillions of trillions of
dollars if you just look at the you know
the us their stimulus
latest stimulus package that's 1.9
billion but it's still like a drop in
the water if you look at like what the
global financial system is
so the answer there is kind of like will
we need those institutions
well those institutions are funded
typically also
by lps that will have their own cash
right so maybe it's it's part of the
institutions maybe part of lp
money that will kind of move into the
space but yeah i do think you need to
pick you know some of the big
institutions to also come in and then
we're not talking about 52 billion
anymore which could be a single fund
right we're looking at about multiples
of that and and seeing that grow like
that
and then needs liquidity right that's
where a lot of the yield is coming from
at the moment so there's lots of
opportunity there
yeah one of the most interesting aspects
of just all the on-chain
uh applications is uh this whole idea of
transparency of data
right and the fact that uh you know
coinbase first let's say uniswap
uh coinbase we all wait for the
financial uh
um kind of reveal right we wait for the
conference call
uh we're all trying to figure out you
know what are they doing and we
basically get this periodic check in on
a quarterly basis
but with a decentralized exchange we get
to see it
every day minute by minute and we know
exactly what's going on and so it's like
that's right as
as an investor which one is actually
better well i would love the real-time
data rather than the
kind of static periodic data and so it
just feels like
um you know some of the centralized
companies aren't ever going to be able
to get there just because the way that
they're built but the new
kind of era or the new industry is going
to eventually become the default and the
standard
that's right and even if you look at
today right i mean coinbase i mean the
markets were open i think 9 9 30 a.m
um you know coinbase is is you know
supposed to be public right but it
it's still at 250 at least before a
check before the call
and that's because it takes some time
for these systems to work and it shares
the list and
you know which and it's you know at the
end of the day it's the system works
but if you look at like you know let's
say that you want to list uh you know
you want to list sovereign you know
what we did today you can do that
probably on ftx and it will
it will be listed like you know the next
second right if you you prepare it
properly so i think
you know there's a real and that's i
think what people love in the end and
that's what people get also sometimes
i wouldn't say addicted but they get
addicted to the sort of screens and like
playing with
it it's it is um it's creating a lot of
value for people and and the information
is very helpful for people to uh yeah to
to kind of trade and make up their own
minds
so that's i definitely agree with that
yeah i i think it's absolutely
fascinating and you can see people
obviously trading is one thing uh but
also it just feels like
um you know when you have more
information people come with all kinds
of crazy stuff to uh to participate in
last thing i want to talk about before
we get into rapid fire questions is
uh virtual worlds and so uh it seems
like this is tangentially related
uh to a lot of the decentralized
financial applications that are being
built
uh but there's concepts like uh identity
and pseudonymity
uh there's things like hey i'm gonna go
and hang out in the metaverse with my
avatar
uh anything there that you guys are
seeing that has kind of caught your eye
or that you're paying attention to
or is it something that you think while
tangentially related is just completely
outside of the circle of competence and
so you guys focus more on the financial
applications
yeah i mean i think it's it's it's
definitely interesting and also
you know i have like i said i was a
gamer before i've lived most of my
teenage years here in a virtual world
whether it's world of warcraft or some
of the other
things that have played out there so to
that extent i can completely relate and
see the market there
i think it's less something that we
focus on in d5 but you do see for
example
um just giving one example an investment
we made is in for example maps
right which is kind of trying to bridge
like where i am right now in the world
so it's not very virtual world but it's
you know it's giving you all kinds of
information of where you are at the
moment and trying to
you know lay layer on top of that like
augmented reality and those kind of
things
but also now d5 so they're launching
like for example
um defy applications within maps so
depending on where you are it will offer
you
decentralized applications that you can
interact with so i think that's a really
interesting bridge like a pure virtual
like
when you look at like second life or
like those kind of things we haven't i
haven't really seen
but yeah if it if you know come to your
way anthony would always you know look
at it of course
to see if it it's interesting for d5
technologies for sure
i love it i love it um all right uh what
is the number one thing that you've
learned what's your biggest takeaway or
lesson
over the last couple of months as you
guys have gotten this up running and
started to
scale it yeah i think the biggest thing
is um you know i always learn
about how little i know uh about defy
and how
how much of the road they're still ahead
and it's just about like you know
for me also i try to learn and i which i
try a lot of the strategies that
my traders recommend i try them
personally and i do them you know
through uni swap and you know through
some of these other platforms
and i think we're just so at the
forefront of uh you know
you know i think me sort of fully
understanding it and then sort of
getting on that on that learning curve
and i think there's so much still still
ahead and the
developments go so fast so quickly um
that i think that's what's really
exciting and that makes that makes it
also an intellectual challenge for me so
i am
i'm very uh much driven by intellectual
challenges and i think dfi is offering
that just like sakfi
gave me an intellectual challenge of
like how can i lend against private
assets
that you know that i cannot value on a
day-by-day
intro market trading basis like how do i
do that and i think
the the d5 is the same sort of
interesting sort of
steep learning curve that i'm fascinated
by and that i'm still learning
about every day yeah i love it it makes
uh makes a ton of sense
uh i got three questions rapid fire and
then you'll get to ask me one to wrap us
up
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
wow that's a very that's a very good
question so i am like
i am not really like a book reader but i
read a lot
i am um i'm a massive fan of
documentaries
and there is uh there is a documentary
on on masterclass actually
uh which is one of the best that it's by
it's a canadian astronaut
that talks about like what it takes to
get into space
and what he really taught me is that
like in space and in space travel
nothing is done by chance so he's never
nervous and he he goes and explains like
why that's the case
is because every every single outcome
they have sort of predefined
and they know about and they have sort
of um they've thought about and he's
done it in his head and what makes me so
fascinating is about
how calm he can be and how sort of a
methodological he can be about
like his thinking process and how he
does that and i take a lot of learning
learning from that also when you have
complicated problems in
you know in business or whether it's
like you know i'm a computer science
major when it's
whether it's about like programming sort
of problems to really think apply that
methodology to kind of
see how you can get to an answer and
that's one of the most fascinating like
series that i've seen in
a very long time yeah i haven't seen
that i'll have to watch it it sounds
very very interesting
uh and i love that you like
documentaries because i'm the uh the
same way i was just watching uh
white white boy rick on on netflix which
is the old
detroit drug dealer that maybe uh wasn't
as big of a deal as they thought he was
um comes from our friends over at uh
eight sleep
uh they've got this thermoregulated bed
and uh essentially uh i sleep on like an
ice cube and i used to sleep like six
seven hours or really five or six hours
uh and now sleep like eight hours a
night uh completely changed my life and
and makes me much more well-rested
what's your sleep schedule
how much do you sleep how has that
changed over the years
so my sleep schedule is terrible so i
have this i have this brain
that i can't shut off so when i go to
bed the reason i watch so many
documentaries is i
look for those that you know and it's
like david attenborough or brian cox or
like some of these more intellectual
sort of stimulating documentaries
because at some point they'll make me go
to sleep um and i've actually it's funny
you mentioned this because a friend of
mine actually recommended something to
say me that's like this sort of
it's like a water batter it's something
that that makes it cooler that
apparently makes you sleep better
um so that's that's and he's apparently
uh for my birthday which is tomorrow
he's apparently sending me one of those
uh
one of those to my hotel so we'll see
oh that's amazing all right well i'll
let you know in our next episode
i love it uh last question is aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
that's a very good question so i think
if aliens is around like
extraterrestrial life
right i think you have like what is
called like uh it's called the drax
equation or something like that
uh which sort of calculates the
probability of there to be
you know extraterrestrial life and for
me it's very hard to
think that there's nothing out there you
know especially most of my documentaries
are about space right um so so just
mathematically it's very hard to think
that there's nothing there but the
problem is is
the the mathematical probability that we
haven't found anything
uh is also not really helping us right
we should have by now maybe
find something so there there's this
constant you know it's not going to be a
complete answer to your question
but there's constant two voices in my
head where one says you know there's
nothing but the other says but there
must be something and i'm still
struggling to see which one
you know which one is going to win it
might require some more hours so
documentaries
uh well i'm in the camp of like it's
there we just aren't going to come in
contact because it's too far away
right right it's like like the galaxy's
just so big and the technology that we
have it just is nearly impossible
uh to go ahead and come in contact so
we'll see
uh what uh what one question you have
for me
well i think the the one question i i
would have for you is you know
you see defy right and i'm going to
stick it to sort of d5 you see so many
of these different
areas developing right so we we at d5 we
define technologies rather we track of
course prediction markets like lending
stable points and stuff and you asked me
that question
kind of where i see that market but i i
would be interested to get your
perspective like where do you really see
uh the applications developing right so
really like
adoption from users right because
there's one thing about like sort of a
token going up because there's price
dynamics and etc
but where do you really get most excited
about real sort of d5 adoption when we
look at
real world applications yeah i mean look
i think that
uh every single thing that is analog
it's going to become digital
right the digital versions will be
bigger than the analog and i also think
all the decentralized versions of these
products can be bigger than the
centralized versions and so
uh it's pretty incredible when you start
to think about um
you know just kind of where where the
world is headed is like
digital decentralized products end up
being the most valuable things and so
uh obviously the decentralized financial
applications are gonna
accrue tons of value and so um you know
i'm probably less
uh tribal about like where do they get
built right if you kind of think
about uh sovereign being built on
bitcoin if you think about like a
uniswap or
uh ave or whatever being built elsewhere
like it just ends up being this really
interesting thing of like i think the
the technology community is arguing over
uh and debating where exactly this stuff
all happens but to the average user like
they're never going to know or care
right like in the final version it's
just going to be hey does this
work or not can i do what i want to do
or not um and so i tend to spend more
time thinking about that more so than
like
you know what's the transaction speed of
a specific uh blockchain or anything
like that
right and maybe the one follow-up
question if amazed and because you have
this natural thing where
where i'm still struggling to see how it
will evolve like let's say for example
you need a mortgage for your house right
a house is not something we can ever
make digital
right but do you do you foresee that we
you know that that
eventually will also happen in a
decentralized fashion or do you think
we are far away from those kind of like
bridges between us to you know
centralized world effectively in a
decentralized world how do you
how do you see that kind of time frame i
i think that uh
decentralization is going to be the
default um and so there will be bridges
there will be kind of this transition
over time
i don't think that you kill the
centralized version uh in totality right
like it will still exist yeah
um and it'll be kind of this coexistence
but i do think that
it's almost like a weighing machine
right now it's like you know 99
uh importance and adoption of
centralization and one percent
decentralization
eventually that'll go like 80 20 then 50
50. then it'll flip and it'll go you
know 75
20 and then uh 25 and then maybe at some
point it gets to like 90 10
right in favor of decentralization for
centralization uh but i think that just
you know the world's not black and white
it's much more gray and that's kind of
how we're uh we're transitioning here
yeah no i would i would agree with that
yeah yeah
um all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about d5 technologies
yeah we just launched our uh our our new
website uh it's completely cleaned up
and uh and kind of uh up to date so it's
d5.tech
so it's very easy easy domain name so
that's kind of where you can find more
and then we have we have a ticker on the
neo exchange in canada
which is just a ticker defy so that's
that's really easy
and in the us we're on the otc as rd naf
if people i want to look for it so those
are the two main i think for your
audience is the two main tickers
uh d5 uh on the neo and an rd naf
on the otc in the us awesome man you
guys did a fantastic job i'm excited to
uh to be along with the ride
uh and we will uh we'll have to continue
to uh to talk as you guys continue to be
off business
awesome thanks for having me uh anthony